let's get to it let's do it the snyder
cuts jesus
here get to it let's get to it
oh my god
[Music]
superman
that's the iris west scene
come at me bro that looks it looks
better
don't do it miles dice sideless
oh yeah that looks better
[Music]
my goodness
[Music]
super beings hundreds of other planets
he's destroyed right and we have to
assume he's won
i don't care how many demons
dude yes
yes only on hbo max
oh my god can you hear that let's watch
it again john
it's being purchased let's watch it
again we can all agree now
this is going to be an entirely
different thing because i still see some
people in common boxes
who are like i don't see how this could
be a different thing
come on a statement of the tone
not to mention new imagery a whole bunch
of new imagery
a whole bunch yeah so true there could
be like that's not in the other cut
that's really gonna cut that's one of
the other kind
of things next snyder has literally been
on twitter like getting into it with
critics who are like oh my saturday
morning cartoons version of the old
justice league movie
i never know how to properly pronounce
this u-x-a-s axes
[Music]
i love that he chose this song the
apocalyptic time that justice league
logo is beautiful
he does love his like classic folk
rock songs
oh my god i actually love that we're
going to be able to get
more victor stone here man yeah dude
that's not either one that's not a new
one
[Music]
why are you watching this so much on my
own this is a [ __ ]
i'm just going to keep watching over
again
mom oh it's going to try
dude
release the herd cut
wow
you already feel more of that complexity
with cyborg so much already at this
point in the trailer
so much complexity with cyborg when it
really does feel like an emotional
ensemble you know i mean cyborgs have
tortured soul yeah and this stepping
wolf
does look improved i think like looking
at it here definitely
and all this with the finale just the
color correction of it like it's
original color palette that it was
supposed to go with yeah
i can't believe this is actually finally
happening i know
i'm talking both his mom and lois so
i don't care how many demons
damn straight just us united
see i don't know if they shot all the
dark side stuff at the ending there i'm
pretty sure
like the justice league they're
referring to darkseid right if i'm not
mistaken the the original ending for
was supposed to be justice league part
one was
that steppenwolf was going to be
defeated and that he was trying to
attend mother boxes because
steppenwolf's mother's soul was trapped
in the mother boxes and he wanted to
unleash her so he's going against
darkseid and then darkseid
i think punishes him or kills him at the
end i i i don't fully
remember the exact way it was supposed
to end and then darkseid was supposed to
appear setting up for justice league
part two
so my question is is you know this
is dark side all that part two footage
with them
going up against dark side is that in
here was that
shot already i don't know but bottom
line
like looking at everything here i mean
the imagery does look
absolutely gorgeous and beautiful i'm
halfway through the second season of
doom patrol and then you know from
watching more dc animated movies and
such
i've really become much more acquainted
more accustomed to
the character of cyborg he is such a
tortured
soul and his relationship with his
father silas is so
so complex i love that so much of this
trailer is really honing in on that
really focusing in on that
and even at that scene at the cemetery
i'm assuming that's his mother's grave
the tortured soul that cyborg is and ray
fisher you know
he's got all that like legal battle
stuff going on but
i'm really happy he's getting a true
chance to shine here
in this trailer like everything looks
absolutely epic and beautiful black
suit superman all the way take it away i
need to compose myself for a little bit
no i mean this just completely uh
overwhelmed me at first yeah just
because
it is just hard to believe that it's
real and yeah i mean this felt like zack
snyder very much
taking it back and putting his stamp on
it especially with the choice of the
leonard cohen song
it kind of reminded me of watchmen or
various other movies and
you know as an establisher of tone
usually the soundtrack is a big part of
that too
and yeah i just i got this very much
emotional ensemble vibe from this
trailer it's like you talked about
there's a lot of depth with cyborg and
i'm glad that it looks like we're going
to
be able to see a good amount more of
that because that's one thing that like
while
in the original cut the theatrical cut i
liked cyborg one of the most uh
i still thought he could have had more
character development and whatnot and
yeah i mean having the steppenwolf as
he's teased
in the original cut of bvs looking
really gnarly and everything yeah this
just looks like such a
more formidable more heavy and yeah more
adult
and and you know since the justice
league premiered years ago
i've kind of softened up to the idea of
zack snyder's vision being for
as he puts it as he's even put it this
afternoon for adults
seeing everything recolor corrected
seeing some of this new footage getting
to know that we'll have some more
personal stuff with flash too
i guess we're just never going to talk
about this stuff he was on the panel
earlier and it was fine but yeah this
this looks
totally like a fan treat and now the
only thing i'm still wondering is what's
the format
i gotta say man like dark side looks
great
and also looking back at the whedon
version
one thing that like i can confidently
say is that there wasn't
an action scene or a set piece that i
was like oh man but
that action scene you know it's like man
of steel it has like at least
two i could think of batman v superman
has the warehouse fight with batman
here i'm like oh you know it's gonna be
a few yeah action scenes that are like
oh my god this is what it'd be great to
see in the theaters
yeah yeah i'm looking forward to
hopefully some characters surprising us
by who gets to have like a particularly
shining action moment or something like
that because
yeah this just looks so much more
expansive too it just looks like a
bigger broader movie
and then you know with the way dcu has
been maturing and then
even watching the like the live action
shows that dc's been putting out
as especially something like doom patrol
i'm all for like
the quote-unquote the adult version of
justice i
really am yeah and i mean as much as i
again i've been on the record i i did
not like the theatrical kind of bbs but
i watched just recently the
ultimate edition and that movie as an
indicator for what this might be like as
compared to
somebody else's complete vision i feel
like yeah there is a lot that zack
snyder does bring
to those heavier themes and in the
expanded version of that movie i thought
it
explored its themes a lot better and so
now i'm hoping that this justice league
uh movie can do the same thing and maybe
have more on its mind than just being a
saturday morning cartoon or something
like that
you know guys what did you think of this
footage how [ __ ] excited are you
leave your thoughts down below oh my god
so overwhelmed is it everything you
hoped
[Music]
subscribe click that bell
catch you guys soon
[Music]
you